the idea that the market is always rational and
that people always make these rational decisions
is utter nonsense you want to live your
dream and and the beauty of doing that
as quickly as possible is that as soon as
you start living it that dream will change
your dreams grow be patient have a few companies
that you really do understand and buy them when
the market fluctuates which it inevitably will and
that's that's it there's no one-size-fits-all man
hey believe nation in today's interview i sit down
with a very well-known and successful investor
who i've looked up to for a long time named
phil towne he's very well known for writing
amazing books like invested uh rule one and
payback time which i would all recommend you
checking out if you're interested in investing
and he also runs an education company called rule
one where he's helping inspire millions of people
to learn investing on their own so they can take
control of their lives in today's interview we
discuss everything from building wealth to success
to really happiness and really mastering your life
so if that seems interesting to you i know you'll
love this interview so sit back relax and enjoy
the show with the series i'm doing um you know
uh and for the viewers who haven't seen the the
other episodes i've created um i'll put a link in
the description for that uh my goal and for people
to tune in and uh almost see me kind of go through
the trials and and errors of learning to be a
great investor um since that is my my all-time
goal even though i run a business right now
eventually i'd like to shift to uh being a great
investor so one of uh you know connecting with
guy speer manesh and then finally uh phil town
who is actually the person who introduced me to
those individuals without even knowing it so when
i was 19 i went to college and i found it a waste
of time and i saw a youtube video from you on how
to invest your first a thousand dollars and that
video you laid out a specific set of books and
those books you laid out guy manesh your
book were the first five books i ever read
that were non-fiction and without that um path
laid out for me uh i don't know where i'd be so
i just wanna uh acknowledge uh and say thank you
oh you're very welcome those are good books yes
uh and anyone who's interested i would highly
recommend reading rule one by phil towne uh
great book i asked my daughter what's her favorite
book right danielle right and she said well
my favorite book is guy spears book i'm like ah
come on i'm your dad you could just at least have
be a homer you know and uh but guy's book is
phenomenal monash's book is phenomenal yeah
those are that's a great start you had there those
you know one of the friends of mine is the guy
jay mcinerney i don't know if you know who he is
but he'd started square and he he talks about in
his book called the innovation stack which is
probably i think probably the most honest and
maybe the best book ever written about
entrepreneurial enterprises starting
something that's going to be something you know
you're not starting a me too kind of a business to
just you know make a living and not have a boss
you're starting something to change the world
he wrote this book innovation stack a couple years
ago and um by the way since he's he he did square
he's gone on to become a member of the federal
reserve board in st louis he's really moved up
into the elite circles of finance you know um
and jeremy basically said that the people he was
that mentored him were books effectively books i
mean here's this guy who changed the world really
by creating you know a credit system for the
little guy and um and all of his mentors were
either dead people or you know and i think
that's a wonderful way to think about books
and i'm really glad you started off that
way it's a good good way to go yeah yeah i
i cannot express even just finding being said
on the right path of what types of books was
uh crazy because i don't know how you feel
about the education system right now but uh
you know unless you're going into stem
i don't know i don't i don't understand
what's the point on it when you can pick up a 20
30 book from some of the world's brightest minds
it's uh yeah yeah you're familiar with lilu
right yep okay so lilu made a comment to the
columbia business school students when he
was giving a lecture there a few years ago
um after being frustrated with how little they
really knew about our style of investing value
investing he was stunned these are two-year mba
students on their way to wall street they didn't
know anything they didn't know the basics and
so um he said look this is why i don't hire you
i wouldn't hire anyone in this room i mean there
he said no one who works for me has a master's
degree or really any experience with um you know
large corporations that are involved in finance
says i other because they're not trainable
they don't unders they've already been warped
essentially is what he said so i think the
education system right now is goes a long
way to warping people because the i don't know if
this is fair exactly maybe it's not but it feels
like the academics have become arrogant to a point
where they they no longer are looking at how what
really works in the world they're just looking
internally at what they think works in the world
and creating a world based on that and as a result
you have well in our world you know you have
gosh 50 years of modern portfolio
theory efficient market hypothesis
which is utter three nobel prizes have been
awarded in the last 20 years to people who said
so you just don't have to listen to me
i mean great economic superstars like
like uh oh gosh robert schiller at yale you
know have have really proven that the idea
that the market is always rational and that
people always make these rational decisions
is utter nonsense what what i haven't seen a lot
of in academia or even in anybody really even with
warren warren or charlie or is the recognition
for why the market can be irrational why
really smart people who did all the academic stuff
that you didn't do and mostly that i didn't do
um are are able to make that mistake and become
irrational and um you know you see comments
from all the way back to ben graham about how
the market gets irrational um but there but
the why part of it actually i think danielle my
daughter put her finger on which was that these
the people who have about 85 of the money in
the market have a very major economic and career
incentive to deal in short-term thinking
they don't get a benefit from being right
if they're not right until three years from now
they in fact they get fired keith mccullough is
a really good guy he was working as a hedge fund
manager on a sub fund and he made the right call
on the real estate meltdown in 2008 he was buying
insurance policies against those bonds for about
a year and his boss got more and more agitated
that keith was putting his fund money into these
insurance premiums that would ultimately ended up
having making it made a fortune the same ones that
that michael bury made a fortune on and
keith's keith in november of 2007 he got fired
for refusing to back off of what he knew
was the right thing his boss fired him
and of course it was only a couple months later
that the whole thing cratered and uh and so you
don't you don't you pay a very high price in on
wall street for not being part of the consensus
and the high price that you pay isn't a high price
that you like you want to be part of the consensus
in wall street because you stay hired because
a huge amount of money jeremy is is invested
through banking funds and and pension funds
more and more uh exchange-traded funds that
are just passive investors and those well not so
much the exchange-rated funds that are passive
but the ones that are more active are the fund of
fund managers the pension fund managers is hiring
people like guy spear or monesh to manage
the money for them and they'll hire
i don't even know it's like california teachers
pension fund has like 200 billion dollars in the
market so they've they've hired a whole bunch of
different fund managers and that guy sees his job
as managing those managers and he's certainly
not going to sit there waiting for some guy to
be right for three years if the market's going up
and this guy's portfolio isn't keeping up with it
he just isn't going to sit there and the end
result is that the cautionary tales of people like
bruce berkowitz who was dead right in 2010 on bank
of america aig and city and later you know made a
bloody fortune by buying those companies at those
prices in 2010 but fundamentally got fired by his
own fund by all of these pension funds pulling
their money out he he had 11 billion dollars
come out of his fund in a matter of a year and so
everybody knows the lesson it's a cautionary tale
don't stick your head up you know you don't want
to you don't want to run a fund such that you're
trying to duplicate warren buffett that's a
huge mistake if you're on wall street because
buffett has been in cash for long periods of time
has underperformed the market uh from time to time
and you know he's not getting fired but you are
and so that's a lesson that everybody learned
and as a result of that the market becomes what
we think of as irrational is completely rational
from a fund manager's perspective who's on wall
street if apple computer is going down like a
brick you sell it you don't sit there holding
on to it while it goes down 50 so you can buy
more you get out of there so that you can stay
with your peer group and that's what creates
these uh mispricings from time to time and that
when once you get that you start to realize whoa
then just an ordinary person who isn't playing the
game the way they do it on wall street absolutely
can outperform fund managers all you have to do is
do what these great teachers say to do be patient
have a few companies that you really do understand
and buy them when the market fluctuates which it
inevitably will and that's that's it and
then you're done i have two questions on
that and that is um yeah it is so fascinating uh
talking about efficient market theory um you know
people are still holding on to it today even
saying well well now with the internet and and
all this feeds that pop up on on your phone and
laptop like it's more efficient than ever before
because you have all the data you could ever
have i don't know how you feel about this
where it seems that with all this news and uh
media being bombarded at us we're becoming more
more short-term focused than long-term so it's
almost uh i'm curious to get your thoughts do you
see that we're actually moving away from long-term
oriented with all this new technology and rapid
gratification uh coming from the social media
uh absolutely 100 jeremy look at the rise of
robin hood i mean this is a website that really
was groundbreaking they said come on and just
you can come on and trade for free here and it
was effectively i don't want to say preying on uh
naive investors but a little bit right because
nothing's for free and so they were basically
running a little game behind the scenes
where you know you weren't getting the best
you weren't getting the best price when you bought
it and you weren't getting the best price when
you sold they were taking a little piece in the
middle there um that wouldn't have happened with
other uh brokers that where you charge the fee
and basically they gamified the idea of investing
so you got you got all this stuff going off
that make it look really cool um and i i
think charlie munger is appalled by robin hood
because it invites people to come in and gamble
and that's effectively what they're doing
and the more people that come in and gamble
in a what i would i would consider the late
stages of a really irrational bull market
driven by federal reserve policies and an enormous
amount of money printing by both you know fiscal
and monetary policy in the united states driving
this market sky high makes a lot of people a
winner who are gambling right you buy call options
and you can become a big winner if everything goes
up and brings your boat with it so um that that
the thing that's happening in the market now is
very similar to what happened with real estate uh
from you know 2000 on when interest rates went way
down and people were were encouraged to buy homes
no money down you end up with i don't know uh
you end up with strippers owning six houses in
las vegas you know i mean you you end up with
these these major market top signals that are like
holy crap and we're we're having major market top
signals right now i mean not that the the people
on reddit are strippers but but that they're
betting and it's just it's just a big gamble and a
big game and um that has created i think a kind of
a mindset of very short-term thinking and and the
attempt to get rich quick uh getting home runs and
um the end of the end result is that most most
people are going to experience a really negative
result from that you'll have a few people to get
rich very similar to what's going on with bitcoin
right bitcoin is driving a lot of the emotion
around investing in other things because of people
getting very very rich on bitcoin and ether and
so on um by just gambling and betting on it all
and so i don't what happens is when you see enough
people around you who are stupider than you are
and you know they are they're just dumber than
you are and they you live realize that fool just
got rich on bitcoin i need to be doing something
or worse dogecoin or dogecoin they got there's
a guy there's a guy who borrowed everything he
could get his hands on and got 250 000 and put
it all in a dogecoin after a tweet by elon musk
okay and he made a million dollars in two months
this guy and when they interviewed him about this
article about people getting rich on crazy stuff
he said yeah no i'm not selling anything you know
when this gets to 10 million then i'll take out
a million dollars but not till it gets to 10
million so here's a guy who has no concept of
price versus value it's all just a magic set
of numbers and a game um that he's hoping to
win with with a bet and a lot of courage to
stay with it you know so uh yeah i don't i
don't think it's gotten less volatile i think
it's gotten crazy more volatile and adding to
the volatility has to be the fact that we now have
a huge portion of the market invested in passive
strategy which means that when things start going
down from the active investors realizing things
are overpriced and they're going to get out they
will force the passive investors to sell which
will accelerate the mood that there's a reason to
be fearful and we will see much quicker shifts in
the market i think we saw the first piece of that
back in march 2020 where if you weren't already
substantially in cash things moved so quickly
you didn't have a chance to adjust your portfolio
uh to get you know the famous warren buffett
bucket to come out there and and catch that gold
and uh you just had this there's nothing
you could do it just went down so damn fast
that you really didn't have a chance to reset
the portfolio and i think that's the lesson for
the future here is that you have to get your
wash tub out early get your bucket out early
even if you're way early and just be rational
about the market don't uh you know don't try to um
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to sell anything
that i thought was still somewhat undervalued or
something i want to buy more of um but i would i
would liquidate things that are overpriced and uh
they've ridden the market to uh you know sort of
a crazy level um why not get why not get the cash
out of there it can't you can't go on forever and
ever and ever at this rate right so it won't if it
can't it won't and at some point it comes down um
and that volatility you will see i think will be
extreme when it comes down you've got another
factor by the way just to throw in one more
one more brick on the camel's back is that the
baby boomers my generation of investors is a
was the largest um generation in american history
and now sort of our kids are creating another
generation like that and that generation is well
into their retirement years in the 60s late 50s
all through the 60s and 70s and they have to be
concerned to get their capital out of the stock
market because if it crashes and it's down for 10
years a lot of people won't be able to recover and
they will have to take money out when it's really
a bad time to do so and they will end up not
having them funny to retire fully and so we end
up with a lot more people going back to work at
walmart you know or 86 years old that's that's a
sad scene so that also is adding to the potential
for volatility is you have this huge group of
retirees who may make a one-way trip out of the
market and then that'll be the end of that capital
and i remember you also um on a podcast you did
with danielle um because i've been following for
these past five years since i was 19. um but uh
yeah i even remember you saying that and i looked
it up myself afterwards because i was very curious
about it where you know people still say well
you know you've never no one has lost money for
five to ten years when that's just not true
like there have been periods where 10 years plus
and you just got your money back um right
so right i don't think people realize
that as well and in this particular case the next
the next time there's let's say a five-year gap
let's just say everybody can agree there can
be a five-year gap in that five-year gap at
at current sort of headline inflation of seven
and a half percent in that five-year period you
will come you'll see a devaluation of your buying
power of 50 or more that's at the headline rate
if we use a calculation of inflation that was used
back in 1980 that they've stopped using because it
it would require more increases in cost of living
on government programs if we use the 1980 method
our inflation rates running 15 right now in which
case in five years uh what did i say i meant your
money would be cut by one quarter the way they're
looking at it uh headline it'll be cut in half if
you look at it on the the uh sort of old inflation
rate calculator and and so if you're just getting
your money back in five years the money you got
back isn't isn't what you what you put in it's
only going to buy anywhere between 75 and 50 of
what you could have bought five years ago and
that's that's a disaster so they the federal
reserve is trying to get this under control
but they've got a huge problem and that is the
moment they start seriously increasing interest
rates then the calculation done on modern
portfolio theory of the value of the market
is goes negative on them and p e ratios start to
come down and you have this sudden uh beginning
of a of a serious um recession in the economy
and a drop in the market that would go with that
so they would have lots of things that would go
wrong the real estate might flatten out or go down
stock market starts to drop we go into a recession
a lot of people unemployed the mood of the country
shaky um and the federal reserve's job is to kind
of prevent all that kind of stuff right so if they
raise interest rates to try to slow inflation
down they're going to run into real problems
and economically and if they don't raise them then
you're running this risk of having the currency
devalue faster than your investments can keep up
with it particularly if the market goes down so
i think there's there's a lot of different kinds
of risks here that including you know volatility
including the the government programs including
the baby boomers that will make this uh a time to
i think pay a great deal of attention to ray dalio
right now is what i would be doing um i would read
everything he's been writing i think he's got his
his head screwed on straight in many many ways and
his basic recommendation is get yourself
into an all-weather program basically look at
holding a lot of different kinds of things you
want a certain kind of diversification and you
want to get a diversification away from the u.s
dollar if the us dollar is going to be in trouble
so investing in places or currencies
like switzerland for example or norway
or singapore or china would would provide
some diversification against um against
the dollar devaluation because it's really hard
to keep up with dollar devaluation if you know
stocks aren't going anywhere and the us dollar
is going down at seven and a half percent a year
that's that's going to be a real rough sledding so
yeah i think we're in for a rough a rough go here
if uh you use normal thinking normal academic
thinking about what's happening i think we're
in for an extremely exciting time if you are a
monash babri or a guy spear or a jeremy stickney
or you know i think we're in for a blast i think
it's going to be really exciting and this is where
i think many people who follow these kinds of
investing strategies will create generational
levels of wealth here that's and that's going
to be pretty exciting i mean would you be pretty
excited if the market goes down you're able to
buy into it and over the next let's say 12 years
you compound your money at 36 a year just leaving
it alone not doing anything brilliant you just
bought in a bunch of companies they went back up
with all these fed policies and the end result
would be six doubles right so if you put in a
hundred grand you got 2048 1.6 3.2 6.4 million
100 000 becomes 6.4 million you're well on
your way to generational wealth you know
i i think the re those numbers are going to be
doable i think i think people you'll see some
people 12 years from now have done that kind
of rate of return and it's just a matter of
um understanding trimming the portfolio of you
know if you made a gain don't don't expect it to
keep going up it'd be okay to take some off the
table get educated um about uh even not just uh
like personal companies but you're actually
also saying uh paying attention to the macro
side of things these days because i know
a lot of investors within your space
they don't even think about the macro but
i think those times are a bit i don't know
if you can do that right now or at least it
doesn't feel like that it doesn't feel like
that and it's certainly as much as warren
buffett and charlie talk about how they don't
they don't look at that yeah they have
remarkable timing when it comes to being in
uh cash how how does that happen
you could you could argue that
it happens organically if you are um if you're
investing the way warren did back in the 50s and
60s and and early 70s particularly 50s and 60s
where he was pretty aggressive about selling out
at around sticker at around intrinsic value and
re you know recaching up the uh reloading the
portfolio to have another opportunity um which
he was aggressively pursuing right you gotta you
gotta find the opportunities but he was uh out
of out of stocks when they hit intrinsic value
i don't think he does that so much anymore with
the kind of portfolio he's got um because he has a
cash machine that's producing so much cash flow
up into the headquarters that it's not really
that useful for him to sell things
off because he still doesn't have
any place to put the 150 billion that
he's accumulating in in cash typically
most of us investors don't have that problem we
don't have a cash machine that's just throwing
billions of dollars every month into our into
our hands with which we don't have we just don't
have any good investments for so why would we
sell anything you know we just hang on to it um
and often just holding on to it's the right answer
right anyway because the market just keeps going
up but boy i'll tell you if you're trying to build
a portfolio you just don't want to go through a
five-year 10-year flat line where you know all
you've got extra to put into the market at at the
opportunity when things are on sale is what you're
able to save from your you know 80 000 a year job
it's just it's just not enough capital um you you
really want to get your portfolio if you're trying
to build something if you're trying if you're a
thousand error and trying to become a millionaire
if you're trying to get that extra extra zero or
two onto the end of that portfolio then i think
you do have to be a little more aggressive and i
think you do in this market have to pay a little
more attention uh to what's going on in the world
and and not that we're capable of knowing where
the market's going by any means but at least
it helps us understand why it's so damn hard
to find things that are on sale right now you
know at least you can you can see well okay
um if we were to look at the relationship
between gdp in the united states and the
overall market price um when buffett was
making billions the market was at about 50
of gdp right right now it's at 250 percent of
gdp it's like huh where can this go well 350
percent of gdp yeah it can if you're zimbabwe it
might do that right you just keep going up until
the year the currency is absolutely worthless and
then it crashes and there's just yeah it's almost
it's just hard to believe that nothing you know
besides of course that a crash hasn't come when
you look at all these metrics like most ipos in
2021 launched uh schiller pe wilshire gdp just
it's just it's just insanity um which you
know a lot of people are actually buying into
like there are even books being made
called the death of the deficit myth
and like we're in a new era and it doesn't matter
anymore so um that when i start seeing stuff like
that and it feels like 1999 to me i want to go
listen to the prince song it's just man here we
are again where now we have new rules it's
not about earnings it's about revenue it's
about actually it's about clicks it's you know
it's just we have to find another metric because
that old one is just too stuck in the mud and you
see that right there a year before a year or two
before it all collapses back to economic reality
and i you know i think charlie i don't know did
you have a chance to watch charlie's uh annual
thing yeah yeah pretty great and basically he's
making the point that this is uh you know it's
kind of amazing and it can continue and we don't
know how long it can continue but i think he's
making the point that it can't continue forever
and uh when it resets it's going to be really ugly
really okay and i think if you're like me you want
to be ready for really ugly right you wanna
you wanna be as anti-fragile as you can be as
anti-snowflake as you can possibly get right
without without you don't wanna be you don't
wanna be rigid that's not what i mean right you
want to be you just want to be flowing with it
to a point where you benefit from the chaos that
comes that's that's kind of how you want to be um
i i think you know the a metaphor might be an oak
is really really good standing against a storm
oaks last hundreds of years you know and if you
take an axe and you slam it into that oak tree
it will bear that scar for the next 300 years
right forever for as long as that thing is alive
and if you did but the scar is a very small
scar right you hit it and nothing much happens
you take that same ax and you slam it into a pond
and it's a huge splash but within moments the pond
is back to the way it was right i think that's
that's the difference between the high degree of
flexibility and a kind of a stuck you know rigid
system and so we want to be highly flexible we
want to be able to move with what's going on and
move quickly and get back to kind of a fundamental
stasis a fundamental confidence that we're in the
right place in this kind of a positioning and so
the reason i'm recommending dalio strongly is that
dalio is a ma he's the best macro investor in the
world as far as i know he runs bridgewater he
did until he basically kind of quasi retired now
and his job for 36 years compounding money at
18 a year which is remarkable and i think he has
200 billion dollars under management right now
with a b and he basically has been able to move
capital around according to what's
going on with these macro events
and right now he's basically
saying you've got to get ready
for whatever's coming down the pike and
it could be massive inflation it could be
that the stock you want to be in stocks because
they do well with massive inflation for a while
it could be that commodities rule for the next
10 years um as inflation takes off it could be
that we need protection from gold and his idea is
you you you need about four buckets of different
things so you know one bucket might be real
estate another bucket might be stocks another
bucket might be some treasury inflation protected
bonds and maybe another bucket is commodities
and you sort of uh adjust for that since we
don't have a perfect crystal ball but what you
don't do is you don't get rigid and say oh well
the right answer for the last 20 years has been
to hold stocks no matter what and we've come out
really well with that and that's what everyone
is recommending just hold stocks and stay with
it that that is fine if you've got enough money
yeah you got enough money you got enough time
you'll be fine but if you're trying to build
something then that is not so fine and i don't
i don't know anybody who built anything that did
that i'm really curious um now this is uh to get
your your thoughts on um what i've been thinking
regarding my own portfolio that is a hundred
percent in cash uh now this is just educational
purposes this is not advice um but uh with my
business um uh evan being my business partner
and doing youtube consulting which is my business
um i've been able to by by august i will have a
million dollars in cash which is which was my
goal um by 25 actually congratulations thank you
uh at 19 i was at your uh seminar in atlanta and
at the end you hand out those cards of like what
is your goal write it on the back and it was to
have a million dollars by 25 so i'll talk about
that later but it's funny how i actually i'm going
to hit that so um congratulations thank you um
what did you start with oh god ten thousand
dollars that is awesome man yeah uh grocery store
and then uh and yeah now today so it's just been
a crazy ride but you're very close to your other
goal then you're getting very close to your other
goal of just investing yeah with my consulting
business i'm putting around 30 hours per week and
now moving in this direction i would love to put
another 30 hours into just mastering investing so
that is the goal i mean i'm sure as any of these
guys have told you it's it's a dream job it's a
dream job that's why you don't see anybody quit
you know it's like all these guys are dying with
their boots on you know it's like they're staying
in the saddle and and they don't want to leave
um you know walter schloss i think he retired
retired a week before he died and he turned
over his investment fund to his son who was 72.
i finally got the top job it's amazing how it
is not just it's not wall street at all it is
a mix of personal development psychology
investing and truly figuring out what the
meaning of life is for you like you know you see
you doing polo and training horses while doing
investing and you know everyone has their own
life balance which i i really admire it's not
so ruthless one size fits all
there's no one-size-fits-all man
yeah and you sort of you want to live you want to
live your dream and and the beauty of doing that
as quickly as possible is that as soon as
you start living it that dream will change
your dreams grow over time uh and and shrink in
a way it's like you can have dreams of you know
expanding out into influence and then as you do
so it may be that you just wish you were you start
to dream being back in a a small understandable
world that you you you don't mind all these things
going on around you but the most important thing i
think is that life is a life is a river i mean it
it flows and it turns and it has rapids in it and
it has big huge eddies where you're going nowhere
and um if you can navigate that river you
you do so i think by understanding your
dharma understanding where you're where should
i be right now in the current or if i want to
have a life that flows with maximum
joy and maximum impact and maximum
effectiveness of what i'm supposed to be as a
human being staying with the current of that river
where it's supposed to flow is super super key
and if your life is like mine it'll have a lot of
turns in it you know there'll be there'll be major
bends in that river and um and the beauty is is
learning how to stay in the current learning how
to learn how to be in the flow of your own life
where you feel that the change is now right
the time is now to bend around this and move to
this next thing and god man being an investor my
whole life has allowed me to do that it's given me
the freedom to wear a lot of different hats in my
life and and be a lot of try a lot of different
kinds of things and and uh and really just kind
of try to be in that flow and it's weird it's like
it's not even like trying a lot of different
things it's just like becoming the next thing
you know yeah it's that's kind of the deal
and man i can't think of anything that would
that's better than what i did honestly and i
think probably warren and charlie and guy and
manesha all feel the same way it's like somehow
i was so bloody fortunate to get on to this
early enough and wasn't really
early i was in my 30s when i did
you know and um and then you know just that i
was fortunate to stay with it through the the
early part of anything when you're learning right
anything from snowboarding to investing is bumpy
there are things that you're going to fall down on
and you're going to skin your knee and it's just
like staying with it having confidence that that
this will work out to get you through the doubts
has been absolutely life-changing for me and now
generations like plural of my family as we're
now into grandchildren it's so life-changing
and you're you you will have changed the lives
assuming you end up with kids and they end up with
kids and they end up with kids down the road you
what you're doing will have changed all of those
lives forever i mean they they will not have money
issues they will be all about dharma they will
be all about what am i put on this world to do
because i understand money and i understand how
to replicate it and i will never have to be broke
and worrying about money powerful stuff what this
does what this life is that you you pick to to get
into and i'm so thankful that it was your group
of books i picked up and not some random person
who's flashing money and driving lamborghinis in
dubai and you know um which is fun if you're if
that happens to be where you're at right yeah yeah
if you need to drive lamborghinis in dubai by god
get it and go do it and check that box and then
move on yeah yeah absolutely but it is very much
when i hear you speak i always hear the the uh the
personal development psych side of things which is
people don't associate that with money they think
of the show billions where i love that show but
it's just you know bobby axelrod and being being
ruthless right it's fun to see the worst of us
isn't it it's great it is it's such a comedy show
if you truly understand it um but i i do want to
ask you back on you know how to navigate the uh
the river and the tides in just one sec but i i
want to go back to um my thought process regarding
that now that i have this big portfolio and
inflation being as high as it is is probably much
higher than that since i live in toronto canada
so it's not five percent as canada's as it is um
but uh yeah um but uh what i'm thinking is um uh
and just let me know if you have any thoughts
on this where with inflation if this takes uh
i know that i need to have the bulk in cash um for
for because i do see a storm coming down the road
um and but i don't feel like i can be entirely
out of the market so what i was thinking is a 25
find great companies at fair prices if interest
rates stay low they do great well having 75 in
cash do you see any things i'm missing in that
strategy or something i should be thinking about
um as i try and buffer against a bit of inflation
is there any little rate of return i can make
what we're doing is just we as my analysts and
i are busy trying to find those needles in the
haystack right of really wonderful businesses
that really are on sale right now and because of
that are having their own sort of depression which
means they're very unlikely or their own form of
recession they're very unlikely to be affected by
a market meltdown they're they're they're melted
um maybe they go down another 25 or something
but they're really melted down that's what we're
looking for but our criteria is that they have
to be anti-fragile they have to be companies
which will in fact do very well with inflation so
huge moats big big moats that allow them pricing
power so as their costs rise then their prices
can rise and um and that makes them anti-fragile
and unfortunately those companies are
pretty well known all over the world and
are bit up to the moon most of them so you really
need some sort of weird crisis like what happened
in china for example might be a place to look
uh for something um i know monash is looking
around in turkey they're having an absolute
currency catastrophe so you you do sort of
you know try to find where where things might have
gone on sale temporarily because of something uh
that's happened some event that's happened um but
if i if i was starting all in cash and i couldn't
find any of those i wouldn't force my way into a
company i wouldn't say okay well now i'm going to
adjust what i'll pay for this because i just need
to be in something rather than that i i would i
shouldn't say i wouldn't do that i would sort
of do that i would sort of force my way in but
in a weird sort of way um and i think matt matt
peterson shares a certain amount of this with me
um but we i i'll trade that that company let's
say there's a company that's 20 below what i
think it's worth right it's not way down there
where i want to buy it but i will start selling um
i'll start doing some structured trades on that
i'll start selling put options against that
ideally my ideal is i can sell that put option
um strike price less the premium that i'm getting
at the margin of safety price and if i can get it
down to where i really think that's a great price
i'd be happy to accept that stock because i'm
becoming obligated to buy it for some of the
listeners who may not be that comfortable with
options we we try to use options we try to be the
house right if you're gambling we we don't want
we don't love being the person who's putting down
a little money and trying to make a fortune we
want to be the house we we want to be able to take
that gamble and so we're taking that gamble we're
saying okay great i will buy that stock from you
at this very much lower price and you'll
pay me for that insurance policy i'm
i'm ensuring you that you can get out you'll pay
me for that and the person doing that might be a
hedge fund manager might be a bank fund manager
wanted to be sure that things you know don't
go below this certain level uh because they're
trying to keep up with their peer group and so
they're willing to pay money every month or one
one big one a year or something where they will
buy that right to force me to buy their stock
at that price we've agreed on well if that price
we've agreed on is a price i'm willing to pay in
the first place then i have no risk when it comes
to the option the purchase of the underlying stock
i'm i'm trying to buy it at that price for pete
six i guess what the sec or securities exchange
guys would say is well you do have a risk because
if you're willing let's say you're the stock's
at 100 and i obligate myself to buy it at 70
and get paid well to do that such
that let's say my net price is 63
okay i've got a 63 basis if if i'm put this stock
if i'm when i'm obligated to buy it i have to buy
it at 70 but i already got seven dollars so i'm
really there at 63. if i'm happy with that at 63 i
don't feel like i've got risk but the securities
guys would go well what if the price is at 50.
you know you've lost 13 says well yeah in your
world but in my world i've bought this wonderful
ten dollar bill for under five dollars and if
now it's available for three dollars i'm gonna
buy some more yep right so um i love that kind of
way of creating cash flow that offsets the impact
on the rest of the portfolio of the decline in
the purchasing power of the currency and are
you looking at um like 20 of your portfolio
doing options is there about that about 20
um back when it was just fun to create cash flow
it was much less because we could use the whole
portfolio to buy wonderful companies now it's very
hard for me to find places to put all that money
and so we're doing we've upped it to 20 and um i
may up it to 30 uh here in the near future because
there's very very little risk let's say i did
one where you know prices have gotten so out
of hand that um i can hardly do this
thing at intrinsic value right i mean
the stocks are above intrinsic value but let's say
i can find one where i can sell the the strike the
put option strike price at maybe 80 percent of
intrinsic value so i've got some cushion there
a little bit a little bit of a cushion i'll
i'll do that deal if i like the company
it's something i feel like
okay if i get stuck in this
uh this certainly isn't the end of the world and
what i mean by that is what my intention to do is
not if i'm put the stock then what i'm going to
do is immediately turn around and sell the calls
so and you'll find if you if you do that if you
learn how to do that that the premiums being paid
on at the money calls which is typically
where they are when you get put to stocks
they're right at the money you sell those calls
you're getting paid three or four times the level
you got paid when you sold the put in the first
place and the result is this this back and forth
cash cow on a company that you know most companies
even if they're overpriced they're going to go
sideways for a bunch of time and then they're
going to drop or they're going to go up and
then they go sideways and re and reconsolidate and
all that sideways stuff you're creating cash flow
like crazy it's like in and out um over one month
actually we do these things relatively short
periods seven days ten days um and the the result
is i don't know in our portfolio we're not real
happy unless we're making more than 20 a year on
that chunk so let's say that we're able to do that
on 30 percent of the portfolio making 20 that
puts a six percent base on the entire portfolio
if nothing else happens we've pretty we've gotten
pretty close to covering a seven percent seven and
a half percent discount in the cash cash value
right so yeah i feel and since we're about half
in cash our six percent would reflect about a you
know inflation would have to be around 12 percent
that for it to not be offset and for viewers this
is not like game stop options trading whatsoever
this is entirely different thing um to look up um
and uh yeah people don't even realize that warren
buffett is one of the biggest options traders out
there so something for for viewers to definitely
look into and i will be doing uh further
investigation myself into uh yeah it's pretty
cool when warren was getting going he ran into
what we run into inevitably as as an investor that
does what we do what we call a rule one investor
you're going to end up focusing on not losing
money that's such a huge critical focus point and
in order to make sure you don't do that you don't
want to buy into things when they're too pricey
or you don't understand them and so there can be
times when they're just nothing to buy and warren
ran into those times back in the 60s and it's
really instructive to go read his early letters in
the 1960s letters the buffett partnership letters
those are where he talks about his three
different categories of investment where he has
i forget his names for them the generals i think
are just public stocks um and then i i think he
called it workouts or something like that where he
was basically doing merger acquisition arbitrage
and his his view was when i can't find anything to
buy i can always take a lot of the cash and put it
into you know 10 arbitrage opportunities
here where i can make a pretty good bet
that i'll make a decent rate of return
over a fairly short period of time
and he did that to create cash flow and increase
rates of return for years and years and years
now merger arbitrage because everybody knows
everything about what's going on with mergers
that's harder and harder to do there's there's
a couple out there right now which are kind of
interesting merger arbitrages that we're involved
in but by and large it's pretty hard to do um and
we've substituted options trading for that kind
of following along on the on the footsteps of uh
ed thorpe um who as you know wrote the book on how
to how to count cards for blackjack in las vegas
and he made ed made i think 200 million
dollars personally and never had a losing
year i think i think his average compounder
rate of return was 28 for over 20 years
um and what he did principally was what i was just
talking about doing there using using options a
little different way than most people would in the
market well worth learning jeremy for sure i will
definitely be doing that um and on that note um
uh i i know a lot of you know i can quote pretty
much any warren buffett quote there is i i know
a lot of maybe you could say the um uh the the
i don't know how to put it but uh just uh you
know the the the life lessons of warren and
charlie you could say um but i i need to actually
now that i'm in a position with my business and
investing to put in the 30 hours per week i need
to really start being digging into the weeds and
doing the application side of things so
i'm really curious to know what your daily
setup looks like how your week is scheduled like
do you have a block for looking at the macro
side of things do you have a block for researching
options i'd be very curious to know what areas you
really tackle throughout your week to stay on
top of things well my friend i'm i'm an older
guy with with some bad habits and it's really
hard to break them and one of the things i'm
working on is to try to be more structured than
what i am and there's there's a lot of there's
a lot of things i have to be structured around
that are disciplinarian kinds of issues and in
other words things that i wouldn't maybe just
yeah i can't wait to go do this kind of stuff
because otherwise my day can get away from me
really easily i mean as you know we've got an
education company that i have to be involved
in certain amount of time during the day
and um and so that that is just becomes a fairly
heavy load relative to being able to spend enough
time on investing so i have to be structured about
that kind of time so what i do is i go morning
from typically about seven o'clock until about
nine is i read that might go actually i should do
more accurately seven to about ten realistically
i read and read and read and read and i read
newspapers i read magazines i read
books but i read and then 10ks and so on
and then actually no in the morning i
don't do 10ks and it's all just reading
whatever i feel like it's kind of if i'm
in fourth grade it's open reading time
and then um i go down and work out i try to
work out at about 10 o'clock i get a workout
in before the day really gets rolling i'm not
too worried about being on the market when it
opens i don't care when it what it's doing almost
anytime occasionally i might be there when they
open for something maybe an options trade that
that we might need to adjust but by and large
waiting from 9 30 to 10 is just kind of
getting amateur hour out of the way and then
let's go see where the market's really going
today if i if i want to be on the market but
from about 10 30 or so sorry 10 30 11
depending on how long the workout is um
i will be on the market looking at our portfolio
and um or reading 10ks or looking at what my team
has put together in the form of a story all
right we have a very structured story that uh
gives us a a very specific set of questions or
checklists that we have to check the boxes on
um the first part of that by the way is totally
not even proprietary it's bill ackman 101.
you know he's got an eight-point checklist that
he emphasized just a couple years ago as being
really critical they got away from it they
made some mistakes and they came back to it
and that checklist is a wonderful quick
uh analysis we actually built bill
it's an eight-point checklist and we turned
it into a nine-point checklist because bill
doesn't take a look at the value there
but we do so we call it the nasty nine
so our our nasty the nasty nine comes from an
old special forces name of the most miserable
uh uh course that you had to go through like
obstacle course that you had to go through just
absolutely horrible for if you're getting
through the green beret qualification
program and they call it the nasty nick and so
we're calling this the nasty nine i love that
you've got to get through the qualification
course before you can make it to the
place where we'll really start digging in um
so we'll be i'll be looking at those that are
coming from austin and travis and brian and um
i'll be doing some of those myself and so that
time frame from about 10 30 11 just blows right
through usually you know lunch lands on my desk
in the form of a sandwich and we just keep going
um and then by mid to late afternoon i shift over
to some of the education company stuff then um i'm
back out again this is sort of structured to keep
my head screwed on the way i like it screwed
on is i'm out on a horse by about five o'clock
i try to ride every single day even if it's not a
real structured ride like i'm training or jumping
something or doing doing anything aggressive i
might just get on a horse and ride walk him out
and um it's good for me to connect with my horse
that way got a i've got a horse i'm building
into a just a fabulous source he's pretty
young guy he's an ex-stallion that we bred
for a number of years really well bred and
then we made a mcgeldin and uh he's he's still
he's still pretty stalliony so he requires
a lot of connection you know he doesn't
really want to bond as much he's like a
standing off so i'll spend time with him uh
and that kind of that kind of does then then i go
down to my mother-in-law's who's right next door
where her house we build a house for and
she's the most wonderful person on the planet
i love her deeply and she puts a dinner together
every night for my wife and me and we go down
there often a lot of people from the farm come in
and we grab a bite and then it's back to reading
it's like we go to bed pretty early but i'll
go back on to reading again and i'll be reading
just depends on how locked in i get i'll read
anywhere from about 8 30 to midnight or 8 30
to 10 30. it's kind of when do the lights go off
so the reading part if you start adding this up
you see what i'm saying yep it gets too much
the biggest part of what i do is reading
it's like seven hours a day or something
of reading and um i've found that to be
just the most enjoyable thing and and
it helps me be a better investor to just
have a real good sense of a lot of different
kinds of things and it's very charlie monger-ish
yeah if you if you want to study that more
just listen entirely about it so that's kind
of that's kind of a rough structure now in the
middle of all that all sorts of things happen
that change everything and that that happens lots
of days right so i try to have the structure to
make sure that most of the days i've got the job
done and then there's days where i just have to do
something different hopefully that that helps you
a little bit see what very much you guys doing out
there yeah yeah no that is uh that's definitely
um very curious to to hear the different sides of
what people do on a daily basis um and now you got
me curious i'm i'm wondering what guy does all day
i haven't ever asked he he said he he really
needs to read more that's what he needs to do
so um i think that was his main main goal for
for 2022 read more um yeah because i i know
when running a fund you can also get caught up
on managing clients and not actually doing what
you love to do so i don't know if my investing
is gonna go just for myself and grow my capital
or if down the road i do wanna discover that side
of things who knows but um well i know i know that
if you're running a fund with big uh big investors
in it i mean really you want what you want to do
i think is take a a note from warren i'm not
so sure about charlie but i think probably
he did something similar but basically they
basically said look don't don't don't call me
all right i mean that that was basically
the essence of it is don't call me because
i'll be in touch with you once a year um and
you have updates that are on a regular basis
that we may send out quarterly or whatever but i
think having your investors understand what the
structure is is really important because you can
be buried by a lot of good intentioned investors
they can they can they can take you down they can
make it that really all you're doing all day long
is marketing which essentially is taking care of
people so they will stay in the fund or they'll
come into the fund and that marketing side is
brutal it really is and so what you want to do
is i think if you have a way to do this is you
want to build your reputation which you already
have done remarkable amount of work in building a
reputation because that's your calling card that's
your track record and then i think um you want to
use the structure that guy and manesh and i and
warren and charlie have all used which is some
form of limited partnership to bring in capital
and then manage it and so the key is who's
who owns the capital that you're bringing in
if they're nervous investors like pension funds
they're going to be in and out and gone uh you
know the day that you are not keeping up with the
market is the day they start leaving and all of
that effort all that marketing you know the stuff
you watch on billions where he's in there making
all this yep ideally you don't have to do that
ideally you it's word of mouth that carries it
from one person to another um that this guy you
know you really you gotta you gotta get interested
in jeremy because he's really doing a great job
that this guy stickney is an amazing fund manager
and by the way don't expect him to answer
your phone calls because he can't do that
right right you build a reputation based on not
i like you and we play golf together but that
you deliver the goods on a on a five to ten year
basis i'm delivering the goods because ultimately
that's what people should care about you don't
i don't think you want to fall into the category
of financial advisor who knows nothing about
investing and everything about selling and what
they do is they schmooze and schmooze and schmooze
and schmooze and play golf and try to hold on to
the money and the assets under management and if
they're really good at that they're really a nice
person and they're they're fun to be around and
you like going to ball games with them and playing
some golf collect their 2 fees every year yeah you
collect that fee and and and your investors are
all like yeah i don't know why move to somebody
else they're going to do the same thing as this
guy does so i'm really in it for the relationship
that's not what you want you don't want people in
it for the relationship you want them in it
because they know in five years you're gonna
do better for them safer you're gonna do better
safer than any other investment they could do
i mean they can gamble and they might
do better over five years or ten years
but they're not going to be able to do it safely
as in safer than a mutual fund but investing
with you could be safer than a mutual fund with
returns substantially higher than that that's
nirvana for an investor but they have to come to
believe it and the way they come to believe it is
that track record right and in terms of you know
making that decision and of course i don't have
to make it for a while just keep building up my
track record um that uh when it comes down to of
course you have to make sure you get the right
investors or just building wealth on your own
um do you find that managing other people's money
just it just adds that extra accountability factor
for you to show up every day versus just managing
your money um i'm trying to figure out because uh
what would be because i know it's much easier
to just do your own thing forget everyone else
and you grow your capital um so i'm just
curious what is the biggest driver um for you
uh when it comes to managing other people is it
just the accountability or i think the the biggest
driver for me really and the reason i went back
into it was that i wanted to see our students have
an option that they understood as a place to put
money while they were busy learning how to handle
it themselves so my nirvana for me would be that
all of my students take all their money back and
and go do it on their own the way you're doing it
but that's hard for people especially people who
have a lot of money um it's very difficult to just
suddenly go from i'm i don't know what i'm doing
to now i've learned something you have to build
your confidence like you've built you've been
building your confidence for five years six years
and and now your confidence level is quite high
you probably could easily accept 50 million
dollars and not be freaked out of your mind
right but if a billion dropped on your plate that
could be a little scary right so there's some
levels that you have to rise to uh before your
comfort level get you you have to get comfortable
there so you can sleep at night and feel confident
you know what you're doing and so for me that's
that's my nirvana but i decided to do it because
essentially i'm doing all the work anyway right
i'm absolutely i'm if when you're managing
millions of dollars of your own money you're
you're paying attention the biggest difference
is that i don't have to build a portfolio i'm
protecting a portfolio so that's a little
right i can slack off so i love your your
your thought i mean in your question um that
there's a certain sort of selfish purpose
to you know beyond fees and all that sort of thing
that that i have in managing other people's money
is that it actually keeps me focused and it
absolutely does and that is also why i teach
it absolutely keeps me focused i have an
obligation to be in that virtual classroom
on a regular basis and be coherent and have
something useful to say that's current and
so those two things are i think i think really
lifetime things and i mean i don't see warren
not wanting to teach it's you know it's a blast
and it and it he was asked once i'm sure you know
this warren was asked what his legacy what he
wanted his legacy to be right and he he said i
i hope i'm known as a as a great teacher yeah
that has stuck with me uh as soon as i heard
that like that's why i have him and charlie on
my wall the the ethics it's not about how much
net worth they are the ethics they have yeah i
have to i have to show you this on the screen
over here oh wow there we go that is that
is beautiful i must say and that that's just
half of the the book ends
and there's charlie oh my god that is
sonia i look at these guys every day
and in my own way thank them every day for what
they taught me um what they taught my teacher
uh it it's remarkable and i also use these guys as
a kind of accountability right you have a certain
obligation to pass down this knowledge in as pure
a form as you can do it be as honest with it as
you can um while still realizing that you know
you're not going to do it exactly how they did
it it's like i do i do options trades um maybe
more regularly than warren does i know he does
he does tons of them and they're huge and he
does put options regularly um so i i do do
something similar but maybe do more of something
i don't know i i try to keep it pure i really do
um and why not because they're the best investors
in the world and if you want to if you want
to be the best you you follow the best that's
that's that's just the story of it right there
congratulations to you for doing exactly
that you're following the best and you're
you're getting some of the best
people in the world to talk with you
which is really great that's awesome yeah i've
been uh super fortunate thank you um very well
it's been an amazing journey and just even
leveraging youtube to be able to do that
uh yeah so it's been uh amazing um to have that uh
but then also the books like if you're for viewers
if you're just looking to get into investing i
would highly recommend i'm just gonna plug this
invest it this book is amazing so um and uh yeah
it is uh really good uh but the one thing i i
guess i really want to end off um on is going back
to the river you know going back to navigating
the stream um for people in their 20s who you
know think like i will you know my generation
baby boomers hide the generation of building
wealth i have the generation of losing wealth like
i will never be able to create the life i want uh
it just feels like that for so many 20 year olds
what are the key habits that you would say just
have helped you or the people um that that you
have studied uh what would be some of
the habits that people should really
adopt um and start to to pick up on i think the
habit that changed my life the most was when i
learned to meditate honestly um that was gigantic
it it took me from being kind of a loner working
as a guide out in the grand canyon and spending
a lot of time alone and when i'd travel i would
travel alone you know i'd kind of pursue my
interests around the world different places and
and um and i had i had a pretty good chip on my
shoulder from being in the military and so i think
the meditation that i got into was a gigantic
change it it i guess i it really got a lot of
stress out of me from just being quiet 20 minutes
twice a day and um and meditating i got a lot of
i got a lot of this stress out and that was
a big deal because stress stress interferes
with you not just your health but also
the way your mind is working you know
how how comfortable you are at just kind of you
know letting things unfold at their own pace
was um was hard for me and i was you know i tended
to be aggressive about trying to make things
happen and i think when you start to connect
deeply inside um you are a little more aware of in
a very subtle level maybe not even in a thinking
level but your intuition about where to go next
what to do next especially in your 20s right
what what's what's the next best thing for me now
because you're kind of you know people build
a resume and they do it very intentionally for
for the corporate world right you're going to go
to this school and you're going to get that degree
um that's kind of what you're doing here is you're
sort of building your dharma one step at a time i
mean because you go to that school doesn't mean
that's where you stay it's it's just a stepping
stone to where you have to where ultimately you'll
be and since you have no idea in your 20s where
you will ultimately be none none zero as long
as you keep following that intuition it's it's
dialing in something deep inside where you'll end
up being you have no idea it can be so different
than where you are i mean believe me as a river
guide and soldier i had no idea i'd be on stage
in front of i mean as many as 30 40 000 people
talking about this i that was inconceivable it
would have been just like you can't you can't
have anything meaningful there or that i would
even write a book about any of this or that i
would even have money was all not part of my plan
so the idea that you can have a plan to say i'm
going to be here by the time i'm 50 years old
i think can only make you rigid it can only make
you like i'm i'm forced into this box by my own
rigidity and i think having an idea like okay i
want to be wealthy enough to do whatever i want in
the world i love the idea like your dharma i think
absolutely could become a fund manager this isn't
to say you can't have a 30-year plan yeah right
if that plan is clear as a bell to you that's
dharma man you just get going on it right our
daughter is our daughter is a surgeon and that's a
gigantic long plan and she's really happy that
she's a surgeon that's her dharma and so um
i'm just saying that the thing that i learned the
most the most important thing to me that i've done
is to learn to meditate and have that withdraw
from all that activity and all that thinking and
just settle down quietly twice a day and that's
changed everything for me everything i i need to
start doing that or at least test that out that is
one thing i don't do but uh i will definitely um
look up that take a look at it it's not not so
much the meditation per se like the way i do it
it is just transcendental meditations around the
world and ray dalio happens to be doing the same
thing he's been doing it for as long as i have
and and credits it the same way i'm crediting it
but there's a lot of different paths to being
silent inside my wife she doesn't like to
meditate she likes to walk in the woods and kind
of transcend there and just be with the woods
be in the in the wilderness and you know other
people kobe bryant is a great basketball player
in america just talked about being in the
zone when he's playing basketball and having
everything go silent and just being watching
what was going on um there's i think it's an
accessible thing to get down deep inside
and i think you can do it lots of ways
look for what's working best for you yeah
definitely and you know it's funny that we
started out with you you bringing up squarespace
and their innovation stack and with all the
reading the meditation the habits it's almost
you're building your own personal innovation stack
but uh yeah thank you uh so much it's been
incredible to talk with you uh where can people
find you the best besides of course making
sure they read this book um we've invested
and yeah we're online at rule1 investing.com and
uh there's a lot of tools there you can play with
and ideas for you to think about learning this
stuff um and then you know everybody should just
pay a lot of attention to this podcast this is
a great podcast you're doing perfect well done
man thank you so much all right look forward to
seeing you soon if you like that video you need
to check out this one right here with guy spear
on how to start investing and building wealth
for yourself and i'll see you there investing
is an infinite game jeff bezos he doesn't walk
around saying look how rich i am if anything he
says look at the amazing company that i've built